Hello
Freak bitches,
your head's not to get as opposed to get
jostled around too much,
but it goes every direction except it
goes right except down.
I have a buddy of mine who's a professor
who's 49 or 50 and he kick boxes.
He's bars and I'm like,
but you know,
you understand this like you're into
this,
you know,
he's a history professor,
like you understand that this is
dangerous shoe brand,
but you get so much enjoyment out of the
thrill of being primal.
You've actually been in their sparring.
Let me ask you a question.
Did we,
we didn't talk about this last time,
that calcium storico thing in Italy
once.
Yes,
bs.
They bare knuckled football with bare
knuckle boxing.
Insane.
So I was going to go make that
documentary.
Yes.
And Berg I think ended up making it
anyway,
but we were like,
just broken up.
And I'm like,
why am I making a documentary of my ex
boyfriend?
This is really self abusive,
but it's apparently the,
the month that it happens,
violence in the area goes down.
Of course.
Yeah.
So there's something interesting about
these guys who want to go spar,
like maybe they're sexually harassing
less women at work,
maybe they're having less bar fights.
This calcium storico.
So it was invented in the 16 hundreds to
entertain kings.
It was stopped because so many people
were dying and then I want to say 1916,
they brought it back.
They keep it low profile because so many
people get concussions and sick group
kickboxing.
I think 20 on 20 a the only rule is no
two on one.
These are grown men.
These are not young like athletes.
They're not professional athletes.
They're butchers,
they're lawyers,
they're whatever.
Exchange
partners.
Like guys just moved,
a new guy moved in,
they just touched hands.
Like one guy was duking it out with a
guy and then for some reason they
changed their knuckle.
It's also
by region,
so it's like neighborhoods against
neighborhoods.
So a lot of it's like fathers against
sons,
brothers against brothers,
the change teammates,
like two guys were fighting and then
another guy steps in and takes the
place.
First of all,
these guys have dog shit skill,
but it's no,
these are not a guy just stepped in.
These professional athletes,
these are literally guys that have other
jobs once a year.
They just agree to fucking just fight
each other.
It gets pretty far.
Which one is this?
What number minute are you in?
Oh,
well,
okay.
You should see the ball.
It actually.
The goal is to get the ball into the
other side,
but when you dog shit skills and so
funny.
I'm just allowing me that when the
person's scores,
they get this so hit so hard that no one
wants to go
like everyone's like,
no,
you do it.
You do it because as soon as you score,
people just pummel you and then you see
these guys in the corners with
stretchers.
They just carry people off the field the
entire time.
So this guy is holding this guy down.
So you could grapple to.
Yes.
The only rule you can bite.
You can kick in the body.
You can do anything.
The only thing you can't do is to,
on one,
that's the only rule you can bite.
The only rule is no two on one.
You can kick in the balls.
I'm sure.
I mean maybe that's like a general,
like two guys are the only two guys that
are humping will these two guys.
This guy's got this guy's back and
there's a lot of people fucking lolly
gag.
A lot of cherry pickers.
They need to get out there and they're
like,
what the fuck am I doing?
I have a family.
Let's knock these guys out one at a
time.
What the fuck are we doing here guy?
Oh,
someone got smacked in the.
He goes down.
He's got the ball and went down.
Then another guy took his place is just
sort of avoiding the whole thing.
This ball guy looks gay as far.
No.
All.
Oh,
see,
this is the guy gets knocked down,
but look,
as soon as he gets knocked down,
another guy steps in and fights the guy
that he was fighting before he got
knocked down.
Oh,
what a bizarre stupid.
Turns into just like a melee of madness
and it's just.
It's actually interesting to watch the
clusters happen.
Like the energy going into one place.
Only one black guy.
Yeah,
I know.
That's why it's so.
That's why it's so boring.
Nobody wants.
And these guys are professional
athletes.
It's like they trained for it.
Like it's,
it's almost like a.
what's that thing the iron man?
It's like a voluntary thing that they
do.
It's tradition.
If you do it,
if your dad did it.
Oh God.
Yeah.
So stupid.
And so rediculus.
Uh,
but there's a lot of tradition in it and
see everyone wears like joker uniform.
Sure.
What is that guys that are humping?
This still is bothered.
It's like,
Hey,
do you guys get this guys back?
But he's not doing anything.
By the way.
He should go out there when your
commentary like where all the black
people.
This guy's fucking gay to more buckeyes,
getting happy now.
They just took them off the bed.
Another Sicilian.
This guy's annoying.
You've got adoption scale.
Well,
it just seems like a.
You mean a few of these guys are okay.
Pulling people off.
Going on.
See the yellow guys in yellow.
That's when people get fucked up.
Yeah.
They just get taken off the field and
then they have to play.
I think it's 2:20 minute quarters and
then the winter,
the winters have to play again the next
day again that three days in a row,
the championship is four days later and
the winning team,
their prize is a cow.
The Cow.
You get a cow,
a cow,
get money.
You don't get endorsed.
The thing I like about it,
that attracted me to it,
there's no endorsement deals.
There's no.
Nothing's been promoted.
It's just people that want to fucking
fight each other
I don't understand is where's the leg
kicks?
Do you guys not understand about leg
Their Italian?
Yeah,
but they're not.
There's a few kicks being thrown,
but no,
it's Tony Lake kicks.
They're standing right in front of each
other,
but there's no takedowns,
so there's no takedown tabs.
It's just shitty boxing would the
occasional kick this is.
It's basically just like a giant street
fight.
Right?
But these guys have a little bit of
skill.
Like I'm looking at the way these.
A lot of the city.
Here's a takedown like this,
but nothing happens.
So you can take a guy down,
but look at the way these guys are like
standing in front of each other,
like chicken.
I think they probably get out there and
like are like,
wait,
what am I doing?
Let's just pace around and see if we can
just get through this 40 minutes
without.
It's so weird because they just exchange
partners.
They move back and forth.
Like they,
they,
they square off and then they decide I
don't want to fight you.
I'm going to fight your friend.
Well it's so interesting because think
about it.
It's like these are not trained guys,
but it's like if you put 20 people
fighting,
there's no pressure to do it right away.
Right.
You know,
it's like when do you decide it's time
to take you to,
you know,
oh Jesus,
this is really,
what is this guy?
But the ball's going to go through.
It's got to get through.
Yeah.
And then they're just talking shit like
that
kick.
Like how do you get.
Does no one know how to kick?
No.
I think most people,
unless they're in Thailand probably
don't.
I went and saw those fights in Thailand,
had to watch those,
but the point is,
there's.